David Harbour is a small but key part of
this film
yeah and ears there is a great fight
scene between David and Chris and
they're really going at it with each
other and it made me realize that
assuming this film is successful there
could easily be a prequel that involves
David and Chris going on a mission you
know even with what happens in this MOOC
so is that something that you guys have
talked I mean I thought their chemistry
was fantastic in the film I think Harbor
is amazing and he's a scene stealer uh
you know it's a great idea
you know I think it would be interesting
to you know we're traditionally go
forward in in franchises but what if you
went backwards that would be an
interesting concept to explore so have
you guys actually talked about it at all
or it's just like permeating it's just
something to be maybe got it
so there's no way net let's watch this
movie and said yeah this is a good you
know what I mean they obviously have
watched this and they know how good this
is so have you had any early talks about
continuing you know I'm joking around
about the prequel but that's a realistic
thing but how serious has it been in
terms of Netflix saying maybe we want to
continue this I mean there look they
were very very happy with the film I'm
very supportive of it and and they've
been phenomenal like I said to work with
you know certainly when you you find an
interesting character in an interesting
world to explore with with a great
director you're gonna want to continue
to explore it and you know that my my
brother and I love franchise filmmaking
we love serialized storytelling I just
think you can do interesting things with
characters as you progress their story
you're limited by two hours you can only
say so much it's a very specific craft
and and you know when you expand the
amount of time that you can put that
character on screen you can make other
choices with them so it would be
exciting as hell to go back to work on
a second film in that series and you
know we've had the preliminary
conversations a question is you know
does it all make sense can we find the
right story to tell are we are we happy
to go tell that to say I'm want to tell
that story is Chris want to tell it you
know so there's there's still a lot of
work to be done